good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Monday hope
everybody's having a gorgeous day it's a
big week it's a big week it's a big week
for law it's also a big week for the
toast because this is The Unofficial
official end of my maternity leave I'm
back now 5 days a week so get ready for
some more Jackson CLA original recipe
cuz we're back back in the toasty
Groove yeah we're back back in the
toasty
Groove if nothing else that's a good
title for today back in the toasty
Groove check but we'll see what happens
we could say something so funny so
Dynamic so powerful I wouldn't put it
past us I never do so yeah it's a big
week I know everyone's [__] tired of
hearing it but I'm finally moving I
think it's three years in the making I
am moving this is the week after 5 years
and we've already begun the process you
know yesterday Ben and I like I want to
move into my new place with as little
crap as possible I feel like when you
move you always just like acquire stuff
so if I can go in with as little like
I'm becoming like one of those people
like shayen Woodley like I'm giving up
all my material things you're Marie
condo yeah but I want to live like a
clutterless life and I live with Ben
Sofer which makes that nearly impossible
because I said this on my Instagram like
if it were up to Ben like he would keep
a used diaper from his childhood because
of the sentimental value and maybe you
know in a buy he could use it to clean
up a spill like he's so insane and it's
making it difficult especially because
today's like our big declutter day so I
started this morning and Ben is
overseeing it now my uh I use doneand
done the closet organizers and they do
move management I didn't know that was a
thing and they basically like help you
from start to finish to declutter pack
unpack organize so we started this
morning but I had to leave to podcast
and I just know Ben is like taking
things out of the trash bags out of the
donation piles to keep I I just know it
well hopefully they'll keep him in line
hopefully they have like you
know husbands a strong Constitution that
would allow them to keep your husband in
line I believe that the ladies from done
andone home organizing have a strong
Constitution I believe that they do it
takes a special kind woman to like put
someone else's husband in check but you
need to give them you need to give them
free reign be like this man needs to be
put in check you have full Authority
before I left and then I also texted
Kate and I was like listen push push and
I guess there's only so far you can take
it with someone else's husband but she
has she has my power of attorney she's a
pusher she pushes people I I hope so
great I'm so excited for you a new
tabula rasa for lard yes yes I'm so
excited I have not been able to think of
anything else since
fabulous so that's kind of like what's
up with me and what I will be talking
about every single day this week I think
that's fair like it's a big life change
you know law doesn't enter into change
easily like we've really been pushing
her so we she's allowed to talk about it
and I just want to say if any what I've
learned from this process is that I need
to be even more steadfast in my like
stubbornness of change I've never worked
harder than I have like this move not
only like the physical of decluttering
getting rid of things donating things
but also like the paperwork with moving
Certificate of Insurance deposits like
oh my God it's been so insane I need to
live in this apartment for the next 15
years because that's how long it's going
to take me to recover from all the
physical
and paper cleric
clerical all the physical and clerical
work I've had to do like in the last
month yeah but it's a good problem to
have and I'm very excited and I just
can't wait so will we be getting like an
empty home tour when or we're going to
have to like wait a few months until
you're settled here I have't something
crazy CRA to say and I meant to tell you
this offline but I guess telling you
online is guess I'll put you on the spot
you're not going to do one I don't think
I'm going to do a home tour it's like a
little too invasive I feel like as you
know creators ourselves I think we've
evolved past the need for home tours I
just it's it's very personal I don't
like having that kind of information
about my my whereabouts on the
interwebs and I don't know I I know that
people are going to be disappointed but
I don't think so so what you're saying
is it's none your [__] business no
for the people who are on patreon like
it is their business like 100% but I
don't know I just I I feel like it
invades a level of privacy and safety
and I just don't like it
okay you have my blessing like you
didn't do one no I didn't yeah like I
don't like it and and also with my
current apartment I had done a movein
vlog not a movein a home tour and my
apartment I recently went back and
watched it like it was so ugly like my
home is always evolving so I hate to
like put out a it's like oh look my home
is done my home is never done yeah that
I completely agree with I feel like so
many times I've put off home tours
because of that reason like it's never
done and then when I do eventually film
the home tour and then I watch it back
I'm like that's old inaccurate
inaccurate and inaccurate representation
of my home um okay fine by me I'm sorry
like I would love to share but you don't
have to apologize to me like I'll be
seeing it I wasn't really apologizing to
you I was apologizing to the listeners
who I love and who I respect and I'm
sorry it's I I just it's a personal you
know what I'm creating a
boundary we have so few we have so few
also totally random but this week's
episode of the good guys podcast came
out today they have Taylor lner on mhm
did you see their promo photo that they
posted announ it's breaking the Internet
it's on Instagram it is so funny they
had uh Josh Ben and Taylor lner recreate
the new moon poster it's so funny and
I've only seen part of the episode I'm
going to listen to it after today's
episode they're they are saying it's one
of the best episodes of good guys ever
what did they talk about a lot of course
they they had to ask Taylor lot her like
a thousand questions about Taylor Swift
like how they reconnected when he dated
her actually I never would have thought
to ask this question but like when they
were dating when they were really young
like who picks up the bill did you get
his answer yet yeah he was like it's a
good question and like I don't remember
but I have to imagine it was me yeah but
he's like I don't
remember yeah it was a it was a great
episode and then they just talk about
how long did they date for very
briefly like how brief I feel like six
months oh that's not that brief it
wasn't a year no I didn't think it was a
year I thought it was like a week it's
hard to know with those types of
relationships because there's always
like a a couple of weeks or month mons
that we don't know about it oh yeah for
us but tayor lner knows how long they
dated maybe he said it on the podcast I
have to listen I'm actually really
looking forward to it I'm going to watch
the video they have a video version too
so I'm just like proud of my husband out
here Making Waves in the podcasting
sphere a proud wifey a proud
wifey that's you wifey that's literally
man wifey for Lifey I'm always lifting
my husband up I'm never bringing him
down no you have to have a a nice
balance of both you trashed his hoarding
ways in the beginning of the show and
are elevating his voice later in the
show I think it's beautiful I actually
really actually do agree with that on a
serious note like you have to destroy
your husband's confidence while also
lifting it back up because you can't
lift him up too much he'll leave you no
and also it's like but you have to
destroy it but then you have to be the
one to lift it up so that he like gets
all his confidence from you from you and
like you go on vacation and he starts
feeling sorry for himself and he doesn't
know why and then you come back and
all's fine yeah totally it's a mind game
the games never end no baby let the
games begin just kidding I don't play
any games in Life or in relationships
like me no and there are girls who like
play games and guys of course but like a
lot of girls are very methodical you got
to be and and I'm not saying it as a
negative thing I'm saying it as a good
thing like strategic game answer text
ignore like there's a whole formula and
if maybe I would do that if I wasn't so
[__] lazy but I'm just seriously like
I don't have enough energy I'm moving I
don't have time for [__] like that I
think some women must also like gamify
their husbands no of course you think
that the games are over when you get
married but they're just beginning yeah
not I will say before I got married I
was hanging out with my friend Alicia
and I love her mom and I was like do you
have any marital advice and she was like
ignore ignore and I honestly it really
stuck with me she's like
ignore I'm like okay
ignore it was brilliant I love that I
love that well how was your
weekend it was good it was a good mix of
like home I'm really whatever the
opposite of nesting
is flying The Coop I'm best I'm fleeing
the coupe so I was just you know getting
my home in order organization things
like that we also celebrated a little
Halloween early we had a spritz uh
Hampton Water Halloween party which was
really fun so glad I got out of the
house didn't leave the house yesterday
watched football made a chili made a
chilly I have to say I don't want to be
rude cuz I need to be grateful when
someone makes me a meal it wasn't his
best oh I wonder why that is I know why
well we're trying to get rid of
everything in our freezer oh also I have
a question for you but remind me of the
question just remind me ketchup um we're
trying to get rid of everything in our
freezer and we had one pack of meat left
and Ben used the same he usually uses
two or three cuz then we make like a
whole that but he used the same amount
of like beans onions pepper he used the
same amount of everything but Less meat
so I like my my meat to Veggie ratio and
a CH chili to be 70% meat 30% other and
this time it was like 50/50 so it was
like a real chili oh I guess I feel like
real chili is like meat no you like your
chili to be like taco meat yes yes yes
yeah but the chili is more of a stew I
mean we could wax poetic about liquid
ratio meat beans and we do Maybe not
maybe not today cuz we have a lot to
discuss today but I I feel like he made
a good chili but it wasn't like tury
Style tury version yeah yeah I like just
like a meat heavy chili call me crazy
she likes taco meat and then she eats it
on top of taco chips and she just has
Tacos yeah I well think about me
actually I love tacos but then me and
Ben were having a discussion about like
cleaning out the fridge yesterday and
Ben was like very adamant about when you
move like you buy all new condiments
like spices and I was like okay okay but
I have a brand
new ketchup it's opened I've used it for
like a week now but like do you I I get
like you put ketchup in a moving box
like I I get the the thing but it's
illogical condiments and spices are
different cuz I'm going to give you
different answer condiments I really
wouldn't take fridge Goods because how
long are they going to sit on the moving
truck like it's going to be hot and
typically they're not they're almost
done so just let them go make your piece
get Kuma fresh in your new place spices
you take with you spices you take with
you Ben's like no we're getting all new
spices why they sit in a Cabinet why not
sit in a box and if some of the spices
are on their last lag sure I'll get a
new onion salt but like I don't know it
just felt super superlu superfluously
wasteful especially if he's trying to
save ketchup or was he I I was trying to
save ketchup well I think this is
perfect compromise we'll save these
things and may won't save those things I
just can't believe I have to like get
all new everything like this is just
it's a really expensive laborious time
for me yeah moving is expensive yeah
don't get new spices okay thank you
you're
welcome you're
welcome so we have a lot of great things
in which to discuss today okay good
stories tailored was out doing her thing
again giving us plenty of fodder yeah
the Jacks and Mahomes of it all we will
be discussing I know the fans are not
happy it was crazy it is kind of crazy
wait let's save it cuz it's our story
right yeah cuz but like where was he
supposed to go no I understand
logistically how we got to this point
that doesn't make it any less crazy
yeah yeah um so we're going to get into
everything lots of not actually not that
much s news from the weekend but you
know Taylor gives a gives gives us
enough gives us enough every Monday
morning it's crazy she gone to like four
football games now I know and I feel
like they won all of them except for
maybe one no actually I think the one
that they lost cuz they're like six and
one I don't think she was out yeah I'm I
was wondering about that too cuz it's
like they haven't had to experience a
loss together yet no it's always fun in
the good times yeah they're like driving
out of the stadium we get away car
woohoo but what happens when they lose
that's when a true relationship is
tested yeah but the team is so good like
they literally aren't losing yeah and
he's on fire fire his coach Andy Reid
said like T Travis gets better and
better Taylor can stay as long as she
wants that's really really cute who did
they play yesterday the lack lack the
lack the CH the Chargers the Chargers
not charging on my iPad the LA Chargers
are not charging on me iPad they
certainly weren't charging yesterday not
in the slightest they should call
themselves the Los
Angeles dead batteries charge yeah like
they were charging nothing no they were
not charged up they were charging nobody
and the MC what do they call that
announcer uh host uh broadcaster
broadcaster broadcaster uh had a slip of
the tongue he called the them the San
Diego Chargers which was their name for
many years yeah I would have slipped and
called them the Los Angeles Rams I would
have slipped and every time it said Lac
I'm like oh the Clippers I call them
lack yeah I call them the Chargers to be
real like that's actually what I call
them I call them lack and law I call
them
lactation Lac and La lack and La they
sound like celebrity baby twins they
do lack and L I'm so I watched football
all day yesterday like I'm so in the
know it's crazy I watched a little
football last night very calming sport
really was good energy I watch the
Eagles play the fins who won the fins
Dolphins Fins Up that's they say that's
a good question because I have a problem
with 8:00 football like I'm going to
sleep in the fourth quarter yeah the
Eagles won okay of course they did but I
think the Dolphins put up a good fight
yeah it was also I I literally Ben came
in and I was like sharing all this info
he's like you're a freak how do you know
all that it was kind of like a special
game for the Eagles cuz they wore a
different color I saw their green was
brighter it's called kelly green I don't
know why it's called that or why they
wear it or when they wear it but it was
a special sort of
Affair I wonder what it wasn't their
usual like teal Hunter yeah no it's not
Hunter it's like teal no teal has a
bluish tint so does the Eagles H I think
they have more of like a hunter green hm
I wonder why they wore that bright one I
thought I thought maybe the color on my
TV like no had was deceiving me your
eyes were not deceiving you it was a
Kelly Green
moment huh you learn the more you know
the more you know you learned that from
the
broadcaster uh actually I learned it
from Fran from chicks in the office on
her Instagram story it was like Kelly
Green I'm like what the [__] is that she
didn't explain why though what the
reason for SE no so the thing is I have
no information on who what when where
why how I just know that they did it got
it okay yeah mystery
yeah that's so Eagles you
know yeah um so we have a great show
today it's also been a while since we've
talked about what's going on in Israel
honestly like I was thinking about this
when I was getting ready today like two
weeks ago when we were talking about it
every day like I was really not okay
like I I only realize now um like in
hindsight and I have a little bit of
perspective how like I was really I I
guess the word is grieving like I was
not okay I was enraged I was sad I was
just like a little nuts rightfully so
and now I feel like much more like
levelheaded and able to to talk about it
without getting so emotional yeah no
it's still really emotional we didn't
talk about I I didn't talk about on any
of the shows I did last week I don't
think you did either like with talk and
like bum bum out the guests you know and
yes and we are trying to like do a
mixture of you know talking about it and
also buoying and yeah talking about
other things just for you know 45
minutes to an hour to cheer all of us up
but so much has come out in the last two
weeks weeks about what happened on
October 7th and then also subsequently
like what's going on in the war that's
going on now and I know that a lot of
people who listen to the toast like get
a lot of information about these things
from us because the mainstream media is
trash and the people you follow on
Instagram are trash and I don't think
enough people really know like what
happened on October 7th and well now
that they're like starting to like clean
up essentially yeah like they still
haven't even you know buried all of the
dead or accounted for every sing
body you know the death toll keeps going
up now it's at 1500 I think when we
talked about it on October 8th like it
was
300 no I feel like it was 600 it just
like it keeps it keeps going and a lot a
lot of the First Responders who are
tasked with you
know postmortem things are doing
interviews because what they're seeing
is unlike anything and these are people
who for a living you know treat people
see dead bodies and these people are
like like breaking down during press
conferences they can't even describe the
type of
violent Behavior and the the violence
that the people who who were killed were
subject to and a lot of them are giving
interviews and it's very graphic and
it's very difficult but like you said
like unless you say it people wouldn't
believe it yeah and people still don't
believe it even though they live
streamed it we've seen videos but also a
lot of the terrorists were wearing body
cams and GoPros that um the Israeli
military has since collected and their
actually holding a press conference
today and they've been showing it to
journalists just like unedited footage
this is what happened like you nobody
believes it because nobody believes it
and like you can't deny it they're not
releasing all of it to the public
because I think it's too graphic yeah
but so they're relying on these
journalists
to spread what happened I mean I don't
know why you would rely on a lot of
journalists for anything but well that's
uh a great segue into what happened last
week which was you know caused riots all
over the world not even just here or
like everywhere um because a report came
out that Israel had bombed a hospital
whicha it's a war crime you can't bomb a
hospital when people were Sheltering
there um and when I heard it I was like
there's no [__] way like there's no
way and because if you know the Israeli
army they go out of their way to
minimize civilian casualties they would
never ever Target a hospital that's what
Hamas does they actually bombed a
hospital in Israel the week before in
asalone I'm sure you didn't hear about
it but they did that
so I heard that and I thought to myself
like there's just no way and it all
happened so fast it came out that like
within minutes of it happening that
Israel had bombed a hospital leveled it
completely to the ground 500 people were
inside either Sheltering or just
receiving Medical Care and 500 people
died and the number was climbing and I
was like what the [__] that's horrible
no way and then very very slowly because
now I think today is the first day we
have actual confirmation from major news
outlets we had confirmation like that
night it was all by the way it was all
on video so you see Hamas is from Gaza
launching a like a million Rockets into
Israel and you literally see because
it's night time so they're lighting up
the sky go boom boom boom boom and then
you see one fall a little short and like
4 seconds later an explosion on the
ground right so it's all on camera it's
very uh obvious what's going on but
immediately it's being wide widely
reported confirmed Israel bombed a
hospital killed 500 gazin Gaza civilians
like horrible and like what the [__] and
people were very hesit they were
immediately uh confirming that it was
Israel and then when all the evidence
proved that that wasn't the case they
were so slow and so shy about issuing
Corrections and now I think it's like
eight days later because it happened
when I was in Israel so I mean when I
was in LA so like eight days later now
you know New York Times Wall Street
Journal everyone is now issuing
Corrections and and even the corrections
are so weak cuz first in the following
days when it was clear that it wasn't
Israel they were like Israel and Hamas
blame each other
for the rocket hitting the hospital and
it's on video literally Al jaaz has a
live stream of like the sky and the
border and it's like and they're no
friend to Israel but it literally proves
proves it what happened and and like in
the day after it
was there was footage coming out when
when the sun came out like because this
happened at night during the day that
people were going to you know the area
where the hospital was and the hospital
is still standing so it wasn't
completely leveled the um it hit a
parking lot it hit the parking lot and
it came from inside of Gaza from another
terrorist group so people died and and
it was at the hands of their you know
quote unquote leadership and the way
that without question it was just
immediately blamed on Israel is
problematic for many reasons one of them
being it's just not [__] true and two
is that it it it brings on this wave of
hatred of Israel hatred of Jews and in
turn anti-Semitism so all these rallies
across the country gas the Jews death to
the Jews you know making signs calling
you know Jews trash it's there are
consequences for that type of
misunderstanding misinformation that's
their favorite word misinformation what
do you do when the Call's coming from
inside the house right so it's so
irresponsible and it has real
consequences you know yeah yeah there
was a lot of anti-semetic crimes that
happened in the last few days um that
Jewish woman she was like a rical leader
was stabbed in her home multiple times
and dragged out into the street she was
murdered um an 80-year-old couple in
France their door was poured burned down
yeah they poured gasoline on the door
and lit it on
fire just you know on social media all
over New York swasa like graffiti in the
subway the Jews people pulling down the
posters of the hostages which is the
nastiest most V vile evil thing that a
person could do who are these people who
raised these people these are these are
posters of children like what beef do
you have with a child who's been
kidnapped by terrorist organization like
what's the problem here yeah that's been
real like that's a whole part of the
conversation that I feel like not enough
people are talking about over 200 people
are still being held hostage by Hamas
they're ranging from 9 months old to 90
years old there's children there's whole
families there's grandparents there's
Holocaust Survivors they're still in
Hamas custody the Flyers that everybody
are putting up you know around the
nation are to raise awareness for that
and people are going around tearing them
down like excuse me no and then also
there's this movement to call for a
ceasefire between Israel and Hamas you
know so that they can what have peace
for a second Hamas can rearm themselves
anyone what about the hostages what
about like how can you call for a
ceasefire when 200 civilians are being
held hostage anyone who's calling for a
ceasefire is either not a serious person
does not have an understanding about
what's going on or is just a terrorist
sympathizer one of the three take your
pick and so over the weekend uh two
hostages were released they were
American citizens and there was very
weird social media activity going on
from it I remember um someone
screenshotted to me I was like what Sean
King who's like an activist I believe
he's you know um he's like Rachel doal
yeah he's a Rachel doal but he's widely
known as being like a scammer he um like
stole money from people during black
lives matter he like raised money and
stole it he's like a there's a million
Buzby did like a huge investigation into
like his money laundering yeah they call
him talom X and um like even the
families of people who were murdered who
he's like raising money for they're like
they hate him everybody hates him so two
hostages were released to Americans and
he went online like saying he got them
released like he his network of people
like he communicated with Hamas and I
was like what yeah like through Qatar
because the girl it was a girl and her
mother he said the girl is a follower of
mine we marched together in Chicago so
like I called up Hamas and I brokered
her release with the help of like the
Qatari government right and then the
family immediately was like we don't
know um this Mr
King uh cool and it was the most B There
were so many weird elements of it like
first was this man like admitting he
talks to Hamas like I was like wait what
it was so weird two kind of saying how
he immediately got to work to get her
out because she's a follower like she's
somehow her life is more valuable
because she follows him like I'm only
going to get out the people who follow
me on Instagram like yeah so weird and
that's just not how like hostage
negotiations work like people on
Instagram don't like nego negotiate for
hostages to be release no so either like
Shan King is in touch with Hamas and
needs to be investigated by the FBI or
he's lying which if history were any
indication I would venture the latter
he's known as just like a liar right
which is Despicable Despicable like to
capitalize on some like a tragedy going
on in the world for like your movement
or your following is so beyond [__]
weird
crazy I don't know that would like that
was [__] weird no it's it's still
weird he still maintains that like the
brother her brother reached out to him
right okay so let's say your her brother
reached out how did you do it do it
again do it 200 more times literally you
do that you're capable of that do it
again yeah keep going do a flip do a
flip that was so weird a lot of weird
instag so weird Instagram is really
weird people are behaving really oddly
people are showing their true colors um
yeah still it's a battle of good versus
evil if you see the stuff that's been
coming out from October 7th there's
no yeah some of the First Responders had
said they uh were you know tasked with
cleaning up I don't even know what the
right word is so I sorry if that's
insensitive like cleaning up what and
they found you know women who and
children who were raped so violently
that their pelvic bones broke bodies
burned alive mother and daughter in an
Embrace burned alive after being raped
the most horrible violent there's no
word I can't cut out of their mother's
stomach B embryo fetus beheaded mother
beheaded
yep barbar I don't even know the right
word barbar
because human beings weren't meant to
act this way but it it is barbaric it is
Savage it is
monstrous it's all of those things and
if you think that there's a way to have
peace with the people who did those
things then you're foolish no and if you
care about innocent
civilians then chanting from The River
To The Sea Palestine will be free you're
not helping anyone did you not just see
the hospital that was bombed by
Palestinians like it's if you care about
the the children and and the people
living in Gaza then support Israel
because is right because Israel is
trying to get rid of Hamas and Hamas is
the one who are oppressing the people of
Gaza so we actually we maybe could align
on that and we could free Gaza from
Hamas right the people of Gaza can't
Thrive and have an economy and be a
flourishing whatever when the people in
charge are terrorists who when the
people in charge our terrorists who dig
up their water pipes to make them into
Rockets to launch them at Israel who
raid a Aid trucks as they come in and
steal the fuel and steal anything that
they can to turn it into weapons like
all that Aid all that money all those
charitable donations like they're not
going to the people that you think
they're going to so we need to get rid
of the people who are are doing that are
harming every innocent life in the
region yeah so we'll keep you a breast
on what goes on in the Middle East and
do our
best to do our jobs as well yeah but I
think like you know an update date was
required and don't forget like they
still have 200 hostages so I really
don't know that there's any other
diplomatic negotiations that can happen
until the hostages are released there
civilians well maybe Shan King can help
yeah no I I would love if Shan King
could get out 200 hostages I'll take
back everything I said me too me too
everything that I said because you know
what he has an Instagram and a dream and
a phone call with a line to Hamas yeah
so weird
yeah so so now without further Ado it is
time for the fast five stories that you
need to know is and the fast five
stories that you is need to know are
brought to you by saks.com we are always
doing our best when it comes to looking
fabulous on the podcast sometimes our
pajama uniforms and sweatshirts do need
a little bit of an upgrade and that's
why we love shopping at saks.com for
everything from podcast luks to gno fits
and more sax is just an institution and
the thing I love about sax is that I
feel like all the girlies who work in
the buying Department are cool they're
Chic like they do all the hard work for
you so you can go to saxs and like
discover new designers and buy cool
things before everybody else has them
they're going to be clared how'd you
know I'm like the girles atx.com have
got me covered and also I just feel like
with fall coming up now me like
stripping down my closet trying to get
like the good Essentials saxs is a great
place to create to get good wardrobe
pieces that you can wear multiple times
style different ways and the website is
so fun and easy to shop on so whether
you're going for a cozy Vibe a more
elevated look they've really got it all
at saks.com
and what's so great is that if you're
shopping for like a vacation or a trip
or a business thing their little
categories on the website make it so
easy to filter through and find exactly
what you need and they get really
specific so you can even shop by your
star sign you can shop by situation so
like vacation business wedding you can
find the perfect Revenge dress from
Brands like Christopher esber cult Gia
so like I said I love shopping at
sax.com because it really is super
helpful to discover new fabulous
upcoming designers before they become
you know like everybody has it no first
it's just like a sax has it and tury has
has it so discover new ways to shop for
everything everyday at sax.com that's
saks.com today's episode is also brought
to you by liquid IV you don't have to be
an athlete to need extra hydration
throughout your day from Zoom meetings
and workouts to long travel days and fun
nights out liquid IV makes it easy to
stay hydrated with three times the
electrolytes from the leading sports
drink plus eight vitamins and nutrients
for everyday Wellness liquid IV hydrates
two times faster than water alone all in
a single stick and now the hydration
multiplier comes in three delicious
sugar-free flavors white pea green grape
and lemon lime a proprietary zero sugar
hydration solution with no artificial
sweeteners you got to stay on top of
your hydration like even though Summer's
over you think you don't have to but you
do if you get headaches you get fatigue
you have lack of energy like drink your
water and drinking water can be hard but
not with liquid IV because they make it
Tes delicious and it just works better
for you like why drink a bottle of water
when you could drink a bottle of water
with liquid IV you know get your
vitamins get your nutrients so you put
it into 16 ounces of water and it'll
hydrate you better than water alone with
three times the electrolytes of a
leading Sports strength drink no
artificial sweeteners and and it's zero
sugar it has eight vitamins and
nutrients and it's non-GMO so it's free
from GL gluten dairy and soy as well
it's great for daily use before a
workout I like to take it on a plane I
always get a headache on planes or when
you're just feeling run down of course
if you've had like a long night out the
next morning it can be also really
helpful so grab your liquid IV hydration
multiplier sugar-free in bulk nationwide
at Costco or you can get 20% off when
you go to liquid i.com and use code
toast at checkout that's 20% off
anything you order when shop better
hydration today using promo code toast
liquid i.com that's to St when you shop
at liquid i.com today's episode is also
brought to you by vegamore we are always
trying to do right by our bodies so when
it comes to hair and scalp Health we
find finding a product that actually
works and is made with clean ingredients
always seems like a trade-off but with
vegamore we get products that are made
with clean ingredients and give us
visibly healthy hair and scalp so if
you're experiencing any of the following
like hair shedding hair thinning your
scalp is just a little bit more visible
there's a million reasons why that can
happen for me it happened when I lost
weight I know for Jackie it happened
during her postpartum era different
stages of life just give you problems
with your hair and having products on
hand that are made with good ingredients
but that actually have results are
fabulous I love the vegamore gross serum
I've been using it for like 6 months
with vegamore you can have visibly
thicker fuller shinier hair without the
harsh ingredients every cute pink bottle
of vegamore products are 100%
cruelty-free And they're never
formulated with potentially harmful
chemicals like parabens or hormones so
the growest Essentials kit that's where
the serum is they have a shampoo and
conditioner all to help you know
stimulate hair growth you get to try
more than one amazing product at a great
savings and when you sign up for the
monthly subscription you save more and
you never run low on the products that
you need to take care of your hair
because the key with vegamore is
consistency you have to stay on top of
it so when you're on the subscription
you're a little bit out of serum boom
next day it shows up vegamore sells one
bottle of grow serum every 15 seconds on
their website that's how good it is so
give your hair the power of a little
pink bottle with vegamore for limited
time toast listeners can get 20% off
their first order by going to vore.com
toast and using Code toast at check out
that's v g m o r.com toast code toast to
save 20% on your first order v g m o
r.com toast Cod toast thank you L I was
just looking for a fifth Story which I
found but I was jump scared because my
sis was on the homepage of page six
again I am you are Claudia ashre dresses
up as OIC skeleton for Halloween after
tremendous weight loss and oh not
tremendous there's the picture that you
posted Theo is in page
six Theo's in page CH okay I didn't even
know that I was there but yes I dressed
up as a skeleton for Halloween because I
had to get a last minute costume cuz I
was like maybe not going to go to the
party and then I just ran to Spirit
Halloween and got a skeleton because
whatever I just didn't want to be
creative and then I forget who gave me
the idea maybe it was Ben he was like
OIC skeleton I'm like oh my God that's
how I make the costume like not basic
yeah yeah that's how you make the
costume into page six thank you page six
for highlighting my very creative
costume yeah they seem to like it that
you took the haters comment and that you
made it your own clapping back at the
haters yeah that Tik Tok did go viral
over the weekend and there was actually
some interesting comments that made me
think share cuz someone was like and she
she wasn't being mean like when somebody
can be you know critical in like a nice
way I actually I receive it very well
she was just like I'm so upset cuz I
feel like you used to like really ride
hard and defend like the big girls and
now you just like she felt betrayed you
switch teams that's so relatable by the
way cuz I used to feel that way like I
feel like I've said that like when Adele
lost weight I was like [__] we lost
another good one you know yeah um so I
totally get the sentiment I still ride
for everyone you know like big small
tall short like love you all and I'll
ride for you but I understand the
sentiment of feeling betrayed cuz I was
like a very vocal like annoying loud big
girl and people love that yeah so just
because my body has changed doesn't mean
my mind mind has changed you know but
has your mind not changed at all in your
journey in terms of what like body
positivity yeah I can only speak from my
personal experience and I think what
this girl was referring to and what she
had said was like the way I now talk
about my former self with like a
negative and she's right but that's
something I'm totally and I feel like
I've spoken about a bit is like
struggling with like how to not be mad
at myself anymore and how to not hate
that former version of me cuz I wouldn't
be me without her right and also like
when you were that former version of you
like you didn't hate yourself no you
loved yourself so like it's not fair for
you to hate her now no it's not but it's
a lot of feelings it's a lot of feelings
yeah but I just wanted her to know like
she was right and I need to be better
about like being kinder to my former
self because my former self she was
amazing she performed at Madison Square
Garden you know yeah I agree with that I
that's something I really need to work
on I'm struggling I I I'm not perfect I
know everyone thinks I am but I'm not
well that was fun just to see La on the
cover La she's giving tabloid princess
do you ever make it into print do you
ever check I never check but maybe in my
new apartment like I'm going to start
getting the newspaper you should I used
to get the post it's a good newspaper
and then you can look for law every day
yeah it's a good newspaper cuz like
their celebrity section is just like way
bigger than other people's and now that
I'm like kind of like a page six media
darling I think I'll start subscribing
yeah you need to support now how do you
subscribe to the newspaper like does
somebody come around and collect you
know you do it online it's so it's such
a like
Antiquated it is business that like I
don't know why I feel like the paper boy
would come around and collect my 75
cents every month you know you're going
to be obsessed and how much is a
newspaper
subscription well if the paper's about
probably these days with inflation like
$2 a paper um and you're getting 30
papers a month but it's not going to be
$60 you're going to get a a good price
probably like $50 a month you're lying I
literally thought it was going to be $3
let me go look I mean they've got to
offer competitive prices you because you
can get it all online but there is
something about sitting down with the
paper so let's see I go to new
york.com home
delivery I want to
subscribe what does that say on the
computer5 a week $5 a week oh they're
doing it weekly so you don't put it
together 2 20 20 20 excuse me $20 a
month $20 a month that's interesting
that's better maybe since you're saving
on cable you could yeah put that money
towards a different form of
entertainment yeah you guys I um I
didn't get cable in my new place cord
cutter cord cutter she cut the curds add
it to the
list and also the news of things I
roasted Jackie
for when she cut her cords I'm like oh
my God I don't know you anymore but
honestly the cord cut her life the
so long yeah cuz I'm a like I'm a person
who can acknowledge her faults you know
I think that list is a testament to my
ability to change change and be critical
of myself
yeah so let's get into the story shall
we cuz like I mean it's it's only been
40 minutes has it been 40 minutes 39
that's [__] crazy yeah we got to get
to it that's a new record okay well our
first story is the big story of the
weekend tailored and Travis holding
hands leaving the Chiefs vers Chargers
game they exit in a getaway golf cart
she was in a box with Mrs Britney
Mahomes in front of Jackson Mahomes
wearing a friendship bracelet that said
' 87 has a friendship handshake with
Britney was taking pictures of Britney
and Britney's baby question mark or a
baby I think I can confidently say
Britney's baby okay cool and it was just
a great weekend had by all in the Kansas
City Chiefs Wags box yeah there was a
lot that was interesting a lot of people
were like ging I need to stop using that
word cuz it's incorrectly um were dying
no but like that's a bad word like thank
you like flabbergasted what are you
trying to say like shocked and notd no
like ging I'm sorry like that's the word
wait let's see what Garing means even
though we've done this loud and
boisterous laugh no let's go to thes
source.com and put in like the basic
meaning of what you're trying to say
excited fawning faing is the word and
you know what I think that's the word
you're reaching for when you go for f
always because they sound the same
everybody was fawning over the handshake
personally like that wasn't the most
noteworthy moment for me Taylor loves a
handshake she had one with jack anen off
like whatever to me it was the Jackson
Mahomes of it all yeah I thought the
handshake was kind of crazy because it
speaks to more amount of time that's
spent together yes where they're like
making up dances and doing handshakes
and like not only are you getting to
know like your boyfriend's best friend's
wife but like to get to a level of like
making handshake like I don't even have
handshakes yeah but you're also not a
person who does you know a lot of
shaking hands like Taylor loves a
handshake like when she wins the Grammy
her and Jack anof have this little thing
like it's it's like something she does
you know okay okay but still I'm sure
you have to reach a certain level with
her to get a handshake no of course
they're on L Jackson's not getting a
handshake right and they're on that
level which speaks to like more time
spent together than we even know of
course of course so that was the moment
that I think everybody was dying over
also she was wearing a friendship
bracelet with his number on it to me
none of that was crazy that's just
girlfriend Tings you know when I saw her
in that box I was like oh great she
either got her own box but then I was
like oh it's probably the mahomes's Box
because they go to every game and then I
saw the footage and then I saw the photo
of Taylor sitting right in front not two
feet from Jackson Mahomes who's somebody
we talk about endlessly on this podcast
he's a very controversial tick tocker he
is brother of Patrick
figure Jackie sometimes thinks his name
is
Austin Jackson Austin Mahomes and isn't
Taylor's brother named Austin yes that's
confusing it is confusing the plot
thickens and I was just shook to see you
know these two people in a room like you
know Jackson has been you know a
fiercely thirsty person for many years
and he really did that like he made it
to the Taylor Swift now lot of people
were upset that she was in the same box
as him feeling he's not deserving and he
is a controversial figure let me not
forget he was accused of sexual assault
a year ago like really kind of it's all
caught on camera it's very violent and
disgusting so that was shocking now I
don't there's only so much you can do it
ain't her box it's the mome family box
right and I'm sure she thought you know
of the potential outcomes her and her
publicist tree thought you know this
could have happened I thought it was
interesting he was sitting right behind
her so all the pictures he was was in
and that was definitely a strategic move
from one Mr Jackson that was Jackson
Jackson that was the Jackson effect yeah
because she's in a tough spot right like
she has her PR and she has you know she
can Her Image she can do certain things
like you know in the realm of her
relationship with Travis but like how
can she say like your best friend's
little brother can't be in his own box
right and it's the family box his family
so I understand completely CU it's like
she's a superstar but she's also just a
girlfriend you know and you got to
behave yeah no and in boxes and in
Suites there's a hierarchy and like the
person who's paying is the person who's
in charge now of course Taylor has
powers unbeknownst to us cuz she's
Taylor but I also imagine she don't want
to ruffle any feathers with her new
friends no even if she like got her own
box to like get away from Jackson like
that's going to be a sticking point
between her and her boyfriend her best
friend and Britney yeah and Britney so I
thought it was interesting and honestly
when Taylor first started dating TR
Kelsey I believe on this here podcast I
said that she would be you know
hobnobbing rubbing elbows with one
Jackson Mahomes and just chalk this up
to another one of tury's predictions
coming true yeah she's going all in yeah
on Travis like they're so hot and heavy
and there's rumors that he's going to go
on tour with her when does her next leg
of her tour start pretty soon I believe
in in about a
month
it's International he's not free till
February right so maybe that's why
they're going so hot and heavy because
they know they're going to be apart for
a while if he makes it to the Super Bowl
you had looked at her calendar for her
to perform at the Super Bowl but would
she be able to
attend let me look it up hold on I think
that she could attend cuz she doesn't
have a show on that
day but she's out of the country like
she's going to come back for her man by
that's assuming that Travis is in the
Super Bowl I'm sure he's going to be but
I'm getting the Feeling by the way that
it's going to be the same Super Bowl as
last year Chiefs vers Eagles I hope it's
Chiefs vers Eagles and that the Eagles
win and then Jason Kelce can
retire yeah I I love that okay that
would be so a perfect way to end oh
these are the US storyes the US starts
back up in October of 2024 so another
year International is coming up November
9th yeah literally less than a month two
weeks she's G to Argentina and she's
gone that girl is going going on
till oh okay just all of November she's
out December and January she's free okay
so she'll be spending holidays with the
Kelsey mhm and then February she goes
back again
for March April oh no April she's off so
you know what they they're going to be
spending time together and aart okay
that's healthy yeah I agree also you
know what I was thinking about you know
how Jason has little girls mhm little
girl little girls little girls
everywhere I think of Mary Cosby when I
hear little girl I think of Miss hanakan
also good little girl well I'm sure
they're huge fans of Taylor like before
all this they're probably freaking out
dying I also need to see Jason Kelce and
and Taylor together that's something we
haven't seen and I actually think they
would really like each other yeah I'm
sure they've met
and I'm sure also Taylor would get along
with Jason's
wife yeah she seems like a real cool
like chill girl and a Swifty she seems
like a Swifty ah actually she doesn't
seem like a Swifty who isn't a Swifty in
the sense of like enjoys the music yeah
also I feel like we need to talk about
how like celebrity fatigue is a real
thing and I'm getting nervous about like
a Taylor Swift fatigue it's fine you
can't stay this popular and this loved
for Long John molini said it best Don't
make me say it again likeability is a
prison and I I fear yeah but it's it's
fine even if they like you know become a
bit Overexposed like as long as they're
happy and they'll then they'll go into a
hole and just be together I also think
her International tour like we will not
be seeing a lot of her like when Beyonce
was International we were saying how it
felt like her tour was irrelevant and
maybe when Eros goes International here
in America it'll feel not irrelevant
that's the wrong word but just not like
top of mind for us agreed yeah so it
might be like a good maybe that's the
strategy you know like people won't be
talking about you here in America that
much when you're on International dates
so let's bang it out before right and
then she'll come back for the Super Bowl
right maybe she'll come out and her and
Usher will do a duet
oo maybe no she I don't think she would
do her first Super Bowl like Cameo as a
guest and I don't think she would want
to take away from Travis's moment if
it's him if it's him she would make our
official Super Bowl
predictions sure because we've been
watching a lot of football in my wildest
dreams Aaron Rogers makes a great return
to the Jets and he takes them all the
way now I'm also a realist and I know
that's not going to happen but I do
think he'll make it back in time to to
[__] some [__]
up oh that's exciting I think it'll
be either the Chiefs or the 49ers for
that conference oh the conferences
really I haven't gotten there yet right
because like I would like to see a Super
Bowl of chiefs first 49ers I would love
to see the 49ers out there shaking that
thing they're also I would yeah you're
right means no
Travis I like the 49ers deserve a chance
and I also think having two super bowls
with the same exact teams like that's
boring and it's not fair like other
teams deserve a chance it is boring
except for the Kel a factor of course no
there's so many interesting elements if
it's the same two people but I'm just
saying conceptually I don't agree with
like that the two best teams are the
same two years in a row it's also kind
of crazy that they're not cuz it's like
oh you guys were the two best teams last
year like why wouldn't they be the two
best teams this year not that much Chang
every year so much changes I don't feel
like that much changes no me no not not
that much has changed on these two teams
yeah the the Niners are playing
tonight who are they playing Minnesota
I'm Lally a man I'm literally a man
Minnesota yeah Monday Night Football mnf
see you there yeah see you there go bang
bang bang bang Niners gang Lou takes the
stage Hy Lou I'm obsessed are you ready
for our next story yeah Ariana Grande
and SpongeBob were spotted getting
touchy feely on a New York City dinner
tape Ari and boyfriend Ethan Slater were
spotted getting touching fely during an
intimate date night at New York City
they dined at Theo Lounge inside the Lux
Mandarin Oriental Hotel in photos
obtained by TMZ that showed the couple
gazing at each other over glasses of
wine and nausees I do love to just know
like where celebrities go to eat like
what's the spot never heard of emo
Lounge have you no I mean the Mander in
Oriental if it's one I'm thinking of
it's in Columbus Circle yeah I think
there's only one in the city it's like
one of the nicest hotels so the fact
that they ate there makes a lot of sense
even though like the restaurant itself
is not a trendy Hotpot it's not Carbone
maybe they were staying there having a
lovers weekend so this is interesting
because they've been very quiet the the
news of the affair broke and people did
not take to it well I think it was very
bad for her Q rating and then you know
they were just shook that this was the
man you know who won the heart of Ariana
ground day she'd risk it all for right
and so they went underground and I think
a lot of people assumed that they broke
it off or whatever but they were just
giving us time to digest time for his
divorce to settle and now they're just
trying to wet our beaks a little bit you
know and I don't approve for a million
reasons one marriage infidelity is never
okay two okay if Brad Pit wants to have
an affair with me like I'll think about
it you know this is just it's shocking
to me yeah I do think that they this
wasn't them necessarily wetting their
beaks because they're like not facing
the restaurant they both have their
backs toward like I really do think they
were trying they're out in public
together I can't imagine I have to
imagine this is the first time they're
out in public together yeah but I don't
know they also both kind of look like
normies when they're not all done up I
feel like they could kind of fly under
the radar especially with her blonde
hair yeah if I saw him at a restaurant
i' have no [__] idea who he was no so
he safe and I think if her with the hat
she's just like a little girl like I
feel like she could get she's a little
girl God why do I keep saying little
girl little girl you know I feel like
she's someone who if dressed differently
like you might not recognize it's
possible I agree I also think she looks
very different than like the Ari most
people know you know High pony red hair
yeah and the outfits like I feel like if
she was just wearing toned down and a
half maybe yeah no that's fair they
could get away with it so you know they
do have to eat yeah you can't have every
like room as room every meal as room
service yeah so here they are going
strong
love you love love that's how you know I
like wasn't paying attention sorry I was
I know that something I would do I was
thinking I was thinking about what's
going on at home like with the
organizers I you Che in no it's all good
had so many shoes gone and she's sending
me pictures of like these big trash bags
okay okay okay okay love that love that
sorry I that was rid of me love no it's
fine also I think Wicked would be on
Hiatus because of sag Afra that movie is
never coming out no it was already like
two years two movies don't you learn
from Hunger Games right and
now it's never coming out I'm not even
waiting for it I think it's a little bit
doomed and I I think this affair is like
not is a cloud over it there's a curse
yeah Ariana drop the spirit stick for
sure for sure are you ready for our next
story yeah what number is it it's number
three okay no need to no cause for alarm
Rush yeah yeah yeah um Britney spears'
song Baby One More Time turns 25 and the
story of how the rejected demo birth the
pop star of a generation is actually
quite interesting okay so max Martin
explained to MTV News um how the song
came to be he wrote the song and he had
made a name for him self with Backstreet
Boys and Robin and he was shopping the
song around but like nobody wanted it he
brought it to TLC they didn't feel like
it was a a hit um a song for them he
brought it to Back Street Boys and Robin
who both rejected it and then he brought
it to Britney Spears who was a promising
16-year-old vocalist from
Louisiana and she had just signed to
Jive Records so they worked together in
Sweden and she recorded the song then
after she recorded Simon Cowell wanted
it he said to Max Martin I will give you
a Mercedes if you give me this song he
wanted it for a band called the five and
he said nobody's going to like this song
from a girl named Britney Spears W well
what's so interesting is that the song
itself is not like the best song ever
paired with like Britney's burgeoning
image at the time music video so it was
a perfect storm I don't know if the song
Maybe I think TLC might have been right
like if they had released it or if
Backstreet Boys had released it I don't
think it would have hit as hard as it
did it being like her big
song it
made I think it only could have been
that big with Britney like the song
itself is not like you know all too well
10 minuted version I think it would have
been big with a number of big artists
like I actually can see backet boys
recording this weirdly but like Robin
maybe not yeah perhaps not perhaps not
cuz also everything the back stre boys
did like became
big right right right but like this
being like the tenple song for Britney
it is interesting to to think like what
would have Britney's career been if this
wasn't like her big one first song I
didn't realize that was the song that
catapulted her the pom poms in her hair
the school girl outfit like it was a
dream yeah yeah I'm really in my Britney
era as the book and the press for it I
think the book comes out this week I'm
literally I'm counting the days in the
words of I have to say they're doing a
very good job it's very hard to Market a
book when the person can't sit down for
an interview so there's limited things
that you can do to create hype and I
think what what's being done is actually
very good I think it's it's making an
impact it's good marketing yeah I also
read that her Instagram account is
deactivated during this time which I
actually think is smart I think it is
too because it's very hard to read these
stories and and hear from Britney and
then kind of switch gears and and see
what she's putting out on Instagram I
feel like it kind of delegitimizes is
the stories so I I think that might be a
good idea yeah and also it's like when
you see the captions and the writing
it's like oh this isn't an author I want
to read right however it does actually
underscore you know the importance and
the the truth behind what she's saying
because after all the things that she
went through and the lithium and the
abortion like what we're seeing now like
that's a broken person and it's a result
of all the things she's telling us in
the book yeah
and I'm sure so the way that the book
was written is she sat down pretty much
with a therapist and a ghost writer and
told these stories about what happened
and as she remembers and I'm sure they
were extensively fact checked yeah
because you know she's saying a lot of
big things saying a lot of big things so
I you know it's by a reputable publisher
I think that the book will be a pretty
accurate representation of what she went
through in those years me too like when
you write a book the legal department
goes over it extensively that's how we
got Maverick right you can't just be
like saying stuff and naming names yeah
like you were didn't even say anything
crazy about Maverick but we had to
change his name they made me change his
name yeah cuz you were just like saying
that he was your one true love and you
know who would never hoard shoes
Maverick no Maverick's a
minimalist are you ready for our next
story no no oh my God is my iPad dead no
uh no I'm not Jackie God stop rushing me
today's episode is brought to you by
squir space stop rushing you it's been
an hour Squarespace you guys the
all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online so whether you're just starting
out or managing a growing brand
Squarespace makes it easy to create a
beautiful website engage with your
audience and sell anything from products
to content to time it's all in one place
and it's all on your terms you need a
website girlfriend are you a
photographer need a portfolio
videographer you need to Showcase your
work run any eCommerce site you
definitely need a popping website and
Squarespace is taking all the
intimidation out of it creating getting
a website can be really expensive for no
reason because when things like
Squarespace exist you're getting it all
done easily you're doing it yourself
people are going to think you hired some
fancy firm but no it was just you so
there are million reasons why you could
start a website and Squarespace has you
covered on all of them so whether you
want to start an asset Library you want
to sell custom merch create an online
store showcase a video collection uh if
one one of the things I like about it
best especially if you're using uh
Squarespace for e-commerce is that if
you sell things in person they have a
point of sale so you can sell in person
by connecting a square reader to the
Squarespace app you'll keep your orders
your inventory and your custom customer
data all in sync with your online store
you can so you can sell online and in
person Squarespace is just the go-to for
when you need a website so head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain that's
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain once you're ready to launch
today's episode is is also brought to
you by Dipsy picture this you're hanging
out in your favorite spot headphones on
the world around you Fades when
listening to Dipsy stories you are
immersed in a vivid world where every
touch breath and stolen glance is felt
with breathtaking intensity so Dipsy is
an app full of hundreds of short sexy
audio stories designed by women for
women so if you love smut if you love
audio books Dipsy is the place for you
they're bringing scenarios to life with
immersive soundscapes realistic
characters you can discover stories
about Second Chance romances whatever
your Trope is I love a second chance
romance but I also love an enemies to
lovers they've got it all with their
growing library of fantasy series
including vampires Greek gods fairy smut
you can explore the bounds of your
pleasure new content is released every
week so in between listening to your
favorite stories again and again you can
always find something new to explore
they also have soothing sleep stories
Wellness sessions sexy written stories
to read so let Dipsy be your go-to place
to spice up your me time explore your
fantasies relax and unwind or even heat
things up with a partner for listeners
of our show show Dipsy is offering an
extended 30-day free trial when you go
to Dipsy stories.com
toast that's 30 days of full access for
free when you go to
d a stories.com
toast that's Dipsy stories.com t St for
any of the girlies who love to read for
any of the gires who love romance novels
or especially if you love audiobooks get
Dipsy explore but then also they have
other fabulous things for like sleep
sleep time Wellness there's a million
different things you can get Dipsy for
we all know why you're really getting it
there's no shame in it Dipsy stories.com
toast enjoy thank you la tury's got you
covered she always does she always does
I'm starving what are we having for
lunch ooh I was just thinking about that
I think I'll have a wrap this is like my
first week in a while I don't have
Sakara doing this week so I don't have a
lunch waiting for me that's so sad
that's hard that's hard yeah I need to
do it again next week I I was taking it
for granted honestly you are you are are
you ready for our next story yeah Kim
Kardashian turned 43 this weekend with a
star studded Affair and reveals why
Courtney missed her birthday party yes
so Kim posted a bunch of pictures from
this weekend she had a birthday party
with all of her friends and family
except for Courtney which you know no
tea here Courtney is on bed rest which
yeah we were all like where's Courtney
and then we all remembered like she's
super pregnant she had a complication
that landed her in the hospital a few
weeks ago and then Kim commented on
Courtney's post like can't wait to join
you on bed rest for you know a swirly a
swirly night yeah I think even if they
were still fighting like you go to your
sister's birthday party I don't think
there was any actual beat there all the
girlies were looking gorgeous some
celebs were in were in attendance um
Kendall's boyfriend Bad Bunny showed up
oh Timothy did
not but I think that's fine he's been
doing like press he's been a Pressly
he's working he's working yeah yeah he's
busy um they all work him
masks she had her lifers there she had
you know her uh uh the mom's chat that
she's in yeah it's also um it's very
interesting to see who was invited
because this wasn't like a big blowout
party it was a seated dinner so this is
like ride or D like OG friends so Haley
Bieber being there was very interesting
the Foster girls being there was very
interesting Lauren Sanchez was there by
the way Lauren Sanchez was there Claud
and I were actually on the phone when
she posted the picture of the SL the all
the friend groups it was like about
Mitzvah like come on up for your candle
take a picture with me yeah so there was
like the sisters there was the lifers
there were her like Instagram friends
you know like natad and Liv and yeah I
think there were also like I would call
Lauren sanches like ianka Trump those
like an international crew yeah like her
business friends and leave it to Kim to
not tag a single person some of the
unknowns we were like having to do
investigative work for like hello and
Liz Instagram was down so she wasn't
there breaking it down for us I was I
still don't know who in that picture
with Lauren Sanchez and Ivanka Trump who
that older lady in the sequin getup was
I still don't know who that is yeah me
neither but like come on throw a tag
[__] like I can't see anything yeah no
it's not right it's not right and also
for them like let them grow their 's
yeah no of course I know like her for
life for group like her friend Allison I
know those are like private girlies you
don't need to tag them
no but come on but come on like we want
the tea yeah so it looks like a very
nice Affair it did it was very lowkey
you know even though it was probably
cost a million dollars it wasn't like a
big blowout party it was very very
lowkey I would say very rich way yeah
intimate everyone looked gorgeous yeah
so happy birthday Kim hbd hbd K are you
ready for our fifth and final story yeah
we can't stopped talking about sports
and now five new sports have been
officially added to the program for the
LA Summer Olympics in 2028 Olivia and I
were just talking about this and it's
I'm so excited to talk to you about it
because I find it quite interesant and
it's already making news so the
international Olympic Committee
announced it has accepted a proposal by
local organizers of the 2028 Summer
Olympics in LA to add baseball/softball
was that not a sport I guess not cuz
baseball again is a very American thing
it is but that's weird because you know
a lot of NBA players and NHL players
here in America either play for their
home countries or play for America and
it's like a cool thing I remember like
when Carmelo Anthony and like Kobe and
it was like such a big deal so I I just
guess I never put together that the MLB
didn't do that no and I guess so
baseball for the men softball for the
women yeah that's why it's
baseball/softball that's feels like
inequality but go off right like why
can't the girls play with the baseball
oh it's soft when it's for a woman the
ball is softer and bigger yeah cuz it's
a different sport but like it's the same
sport different ball yeah that's a weird
thing yeah I need the the women to get
on that then Cricket will be an Olympic
sport I have no interest but I
understand that you know other countries
find it really fabulous and interesting
so I'm happy for them and Cricket the
one from Heathers with the wooden yes
they probably feel about baseball how
Americans feel about Cricket do they
watch cricket on TV like every night of
the week checkie there are Cricket
Arenas like it's a huge sport okay cool
happy for them yeah flag football so I
guess that's you know football is
finally going to be in the Olympics but
flag why flag I don't know maybe because
other countries don't want to like
engage in the head trauma of it all oh
please have you ever seen people play
rugby it's insane that's true I don't
know why
flag feels like less fun but groon gr
said he's going out for the team oh my
God that's the cool thing like people
who are famous for their things get to
become Olympians it's really cool like a
cool thing like you know when you talk
about Kobe Bryant you say all of his
accolades he's also an Olympian a gold
medalist right yeah they won Gold yeah
it like almost wasn't fair when all
those NBA players played in the Olympics
like no one else was ever going to win
even though there's like a few people in
the NBA who are from other like Pal
Gasol and they're so they play for their
home countries but it's not even a
question you know yeah I feel like it's
going to be that way with football
because nobody else plays football other
than us um which is why like La is like
let's add football to it yeah right um
lacrosse I I don't need it I'm happy for
the lacrosse players because I was just
talking about this with Olivia I feel
like so many people play lacrosse
Growing Up So competitively like that's
their sport of choice you can even play
lacrosse in college and then it's just a
dead end it's very similar to gymnastics
how you train your whole life for
gymnastics and you cannot compete if
you're if you're not an Olympian past
college like there's no career for you
right but lacrosse didn't even have the
Olympics at least gymnasts they have
that to Aspire to what about
cheerleading is that an Olympic sport no
and that's what the movie the
documentary cheer really highlighted the
same thing where like you go so hard in
college it's your whole life your whole
life and then there's nothing for you
there actually I mean there's still a
career like you could be a cheerleader
professionally but it's actually less
competitive than College cheering
professional cheerleading doesn't do
like stunts and [__] they do D it's more
like dancers yeah that's true and there
is technically professional lacrosse but
we were saying like you also need
another job yeah right it's not like
playing in the NFL so I'm happy for
lacrosse players that they can now
devote their life to becoming Olympians
what other sports and
squash what about pickle ball I know
it's I think it's too new we were just
talking about that too I think
eventually it could become an Olympic
sport but it's too
new and how how I really like so Olympic
level at pickle ball like it's oh you
can but I guess if there's pingpong
there could be pickle ball once they
entered pingpong I think it just kind of
open all bets are off yeah I think they
need to I need they need to tighten it
up a little bit I agree like cuz what's
next field
hockey I wouldn't be surprised if that's
right I think we need to have like a
little bit of a higher bar I'm sorry but
I mean what's the downside to having all
these Olympic sports if you really think
about it it either you don't watch it
you don't care but it allows for more
people to enter into Olympics it's more
content for advertisers like yep it's
just more more is more Tides rise all
shs but it could also sort of
delegitimize the the legitimacy of the
other things right I guess we'll have to
see how it goes like but is there a
limit on how many Olympic sports there
can be
um no this will be the first time that
flag football and squash have ever been
played but baseball and softball were at
the Tokyo Olympics and cricket was
played during Paris Olympics in 1900 so
is it just up to the host country I
think it's up to the host country like
they can take or add any sport they they
have to get approved but like they can
do whatever the [__] they want well la
should definitely do pickle ball right
and and now it makes sense why La would
go so hard for football because like
this is America you think Travis Kel is
going to play in the Olympics
I do uh it's in five years A lot can
happen so true some high schooler right
now could be playing in the Olympics so
true it could be
us you never know crazier things have
happened are they going to ever put
podcasting as an Olympic sport because
that's that's a lot of work yeah we're
gold medalists oh for sure in people's
hearts Claudia yeah so that's exciting I
hadn't also like really internal Iz the
fact that the 2028 Olympics were in the
US OFA yeah well because everybody's
prepping now for Paris that's the next
one Paris
24 Summer
Olympics
yeah I'm starting to see some
commercials when I watch the football
right right you know what else I saw
last night when I watched football is
that smartless no what were they doing
they had like a T-Mobile
commercial I'm happy for them yeah I saw
that peacock is going to start airing
Prem PR League soccer games from the UK
oh so Manchester United and Manchester
City will be playing this weekend and
those are two different
teams they're
not like they just can't possibly and I
just I feel like I don't know if it's
like that I think you call it the
Mandela effect when like everything
something how you remember it is nothing
like how it actually is no that's not
what I was thinking it's like when you
notice one thing then you start to like
notice it everywhere that's not the
Mandela effect oh okay I don't know what
effect that is but that's how I feel
about like soccer Manchester United
David Beckham then I sent you that story
um
Bobby shoot that football that soccer
player that David Beckham's dad was like
obsessed with um yes Charlton passed
away passed away I saw that he passed
away this weekend I if I didn't just
watch Beckham I wouldn't have known who
that was like it
all everything's coming up football with
you I I understand everything's coming
up football oh my God I'm so [__]
hungry
like I can't wait tea lunch so is that
your saying that you're done with this
with this I'm done with this story yeah
well then once the story is done the
show is done you want to talk about
anything
else I don't think so I didn't really
watch much nothing to recap so you can
go I didn't watch much either have your
lunch I'm just so excited for lunch well
well yes but to move to move yeah like I
can't think about anything else I'm
sorry okay so go do your thing have your
lunch do your move we'll see you
tomorrow you want to you sounds like
you're wrapping up do it oh now you're
putting it on me even though I was ready
to keep talking aboutall food in my
belly I have no energy okay well also
the curds are going to run out so it's
not even about us it's about the curds
so thank you so much for listening to
the toast we hope you enjoyed your stay
with us we hope that you come back
tomorrow and that you tell a friend
about it cuz if every single one of you
told a friend about the toast we double
in size overnight but hopefully your
friends already listen cuz they're in
tune with what's necessary we hope that
you have a great day and we will see you
tomorrow love you love it bye
bye